all right let's go to matt in uh
cleveland matt what's going on man
hey john hey rachel hey what's up how
can we help
hey um so i have a question um i'm
starting to
feel a lot of kind of resentment or
frustration towards some of my friends
who are being financially irresponsible
um
like they'll be going on vacations when
i know that you're like
either they'll complain about money
issues or things of that
issue or they won't have jobs i know
dave shout dave says to share your
journey but that doesn't seem to work
listening to the show all the time i
feel like financially winning
is what dave teaches and so i mean i'm
kind of
i don't i feel like i'm the crazy one
sometimes but listening to your show
i feel like the normal one i don't know
um so how can i stop the feelings that i
have
of not everyone wins
um so whenever i hear the word
resentment the word resentment
or resentment in general is the absolute
death bell
of a relationship whenever you cross
that line to
like i'm frustrated with you that means
you're in a good relationship
i'm annoyed i'm angry with you that
means you're in a good relationship that
means there's things about this that you
care about
when you get to the resentment part it's
an ash
right it's hard when we talk to folks
whose marriage when they resent
their per their partner man that's hard
to come back from
my first question to you is
it feels like you have an air of
superiority around your friends
that i'd want to challenge you on that
you you handle money differently than
they do
there you feel like they're being
irresponsible
there's a gap between um friends like
hey i don't make that decision i'll make
that decision
yours feels a little bit higher than
that do you feel like you're better than
them walk me through where your head's
at man
um it's it's more just when they're
going on vacations but um
but i mean the next day they'll complain
about their problems i'm like come on
like if you didn't take that vacation
like
you'd have the money to do you know to
pay your car rent
i mean carly's so rachel i'd love to get
your thoughts i
i have something with my buddies with my
long time friends
which is when they ask for my opinion
i'll give it to them yeah
and if they don't i am it's such a tight
relationship with them that i feel free
to mock their choices and we do it in
good fun because we love each other
right
um but i don't hold the outcome i just
am committed to sitting with them
when things are challenging right so
when they call me and they say
i went on a vacation i didn't now i
can't make rent
i get to say well duh right
but i'm not gonna hold it's not my fault
that they made that decision
that's right i'm not gonna hold that
because yeah there's a level of of
responsibility matt i feel like you're
taking on for your friends and that's
what's like stirring up all these
emotions and so
being able to see my counselor did this
about a different relationship my life
but i wish you could see me but he like
had these scissors and he was like
pretending to cut these like strings
he's like
cut the strings yeah cut the strings
you're not emotionally responsible for
this so matt you're not respond you're
not responsible for their choices
and yeah if they're just complaining all
the time then you can say hey are you
good if i just kind of share where i'm
at
what what i see and in a loving way just
like yeah i mean
if that cost two grand and your rent 600
you know 1200 yeah you could have used
it i mean i don't know it's just math
and
but it's not emotional because you're
you're not responsible for them that's
right
matt can i ask you one other question
it's gonna sound like i'm coming after
you but i just want to get to
a little bit deeper is there a part of
you that wishes you were going on these
vacations with them
part of me wishes i could go on the
vacation um part of me yeah part of me
does wish i
could go on those vacations with them so
that's a big moment man
and it's okay to
[Music]
be frustrated that the the choices
you're choosing to make in your life
are cutting out on some fun right now
that the choices you are choosing right
now are
annoying right they are keeping you from
you know firecrackers and whatever i get
that dude and it sucks
the moment you can say i'm frustrated
and
you can pause and say am i frustrated
just because i want to be going on a
vacation but i'm sticking to this budget
for the time being because i'm playing a
long game with my life
or am i frustrated because i love my
friends and they're making ding-dong
choices
or am i just a grumpy guy right if you
find that
i'm just frustrated that i don't get to
go then you can circle back to i'm
making a series of choices because i'm
i'm investing in my future i'm investing
in my family i don't even have yet i'm
investing in
filling all these things i want to be
able to help my neighbor in any way
shape form or fashion
man then you've got a frustration's okay
right yeah
it's just part of the process and like
rachel said you don't own
their outcome right divorce yourself and
i think one of the hardest things when
it comes
and probably anything in life but
specifically money with people in your
life so whether it's
parents spouse for well no i wouldn't
count spouses but friends
uh parents in-laws right i mean
all these people in your life and when
they make different choices than you
make
and you hear the complaining and all of
that i mean that that's a very very real
thing
and understanding that until they ask
your opinion yeah
just keep it to yourself yeah or like
you said matt already like share your
story share
where you're at if you long for that but
that is a hard thing
for people because there's a level of
control we want to have for the people
that we love because you do see them
harming themselves you're like dang it
dang it
but listen they're grown-ups and they
get to make their decisions
yes matt is if you sit down with them
they'd say man matt when you're not
around we all talk about you we want you
just to have some more fun
and smile and so what if we figured out
ways to do some things together that
maybe didn't involve this
you're not late on any of your bills
yeah exactly you pay your bills every
month so
thanks for that call matt and um next
time you get sideways just pause for
that that one moment and say
is this just because i'm jealous is this
because i'm frustrated
or is this because i'm trying to hold on
to somebody else's outcome man and free
yourself from that i love that analogy
cut the strings that's good